[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
we got anthony lee back
i like it always i like the aggressive
plaques
sometimes it's not with like an insult
immediately but you know it's good
did you ever think about like let's say
you got ran over by a steamroller
and you can't dance anymore will you do
immediately
right now everything about that like if
you can't use your legs oh so the
steamroll
only hits my legs and arms like the
whole point is that you can't
you can't dance you're a piece of paper
like a looney tunes yeah and i can't
dance anymore
what about what i do yeah oh just crypto
really
you've got it all figured out now huh no
for us was there like another trade that
you think you would do or not
i have a question really quick
can you choreograph without using your
own body
you mean by like vocally describing
something and then another person's body
ends up creating the vision yes
like if you were no longer able to dance
like can you
still choreograph like work poor in
choreography
there's actually a lot of like
choreographer choreographers that are in
the game right now
that are like super old they've been
choreographing for like decades right
and so they'll come
in as like the direct choreographer the
c director of the of
the number but they don't actually ever
really put moves together they have like
four
assistant choreographers that come in
and do the actual movement
it's like people do but how do you
explain this and this
it's not at that level when you get like
at that level of like
the the the directing and stuff like
that it's not really about the moves you
do
it's about the feeling we're trying to
convey huh yeah and
just at the end of the day it's about
like the number in general like the the
the visual in general not the specifics
of like how sick is this dancing
but the dancing is always sick because
they're bringing in to even be an
assistant choreographer to one of those
choreographers in the industry you
already got to be like the [ __ ] anyway
they just bring you in you end up doing
all the moves and then they get the
credit it's like you know regular [ __ ]
but how cool would it be
to watch a director go i wanted it like
this not like this
like this you [ __ ] idiots it kind of
happens
like this who shoots like this it's
double finger double
we had this dude who's like mad mad
famous uh
director worked on things like you know
um
a lot of shows in vegas like cirque
stuff right and uh but he was like
a bigger older you know guy he's not
really that well he wasn't like the
dancer choreographer he was like the
director
but then in terms of like when you're
like directing vision he was sit up
there because he had to see the whole
show and he had this thing where he had
this laser pointer what's his title move
there
a creative director he's a creative
director before the show
yeah i see it so be like you move there
i want more and then you like whisper to
his choreography
and then that person will talk to their
assistant director and then the
assistant choreographer run down be like
okay we gotta do blah blah blah you know
what i'm saying wow that's like that's
like film right you have a director he's
an interesting director he just paints
the vision the cinematographer goes to
like whatever
his crew and then they do the technical
things yeah they literally only talk to
like two people and everyone
those two people like spread the
knowledge everywhere else
that exactly is kind of like the cream
of the crop in the industry when it
comes to that stuff anyway right cool
i've heard that hans zimmer the famous
composer he has the same kind of thing
where he has like
his underlings are the ones who compose
it and he kind of just
oversees it and that's this that's the
dream job
he just comes and he goes it's missing
and they're like that's genius holy [ __ ]
what do you think of that oh my god we
need more
you know scott storch back in the day he
was dre's
piano dude and he he was a part of that
team
until he made a name for himself so a
lot of producers as we know it same with
like on zimmer it's the same
[ __ ] they all have teams whatever
happened to red man i mean most
musical artists and pop singers and
stuff they don't write their own songs
they don't produce their own stuff
you know what i mean it so there's no
recording artists there's
always somebody who's doing that so even
when the choreographer like the
choreographer is like
at the end of the day the the end of the
production the choreographer is like
nobody but they might do like
90 of the content that people are like
following lovely you know what i'm
saying so it's
and i maybe i'm just saying that because
i'm biased but yeah so to answer your
question
it's still possible as long as people
respect you enough to be believe in what
you're doing if you have no [ __ ]
limbs
what about his question sorry i
interrupted his question well if i had
no limbs but i could still just do
anything for the sake of the
conversation
would you still be in dance i guess or
would or is there like other parts of
you that would be like oh i would
totally do this thing and do that it'd
be too painful to return to dance
because since you can't dance yourself
specifically because i got my limb
steamrolled yes i think that that's a
unique element to it because for example
outside of that i would enjoy being a
chiropractor really oh yeah that's like
out of nowhere
why i just said that what so you go back
to school then
i never said i'd like going back to
school but if i could just be one
again so you're laying down like this
and the steamroller came this way
and then when your knees your shins and
then your i mean your toes your knee
your shins your knees
it stops right before you wee-wee that's
important that's how it smashed
you would be a chiropractor i probably
wouldn't be able to still use your hands
yeah you can
you have to like crack people yeah i
don't think i would physically be able
to so maybe maybe
i gave you a bad answer because i didn't
understand the depth of the steam roll
but now you know
you can't do the pickup cross your arms
and pick up yeah which we all know that
they do but then also you're saying you
don't want to go back to school so
you're just going to be like a freestyle
chiropractor like how does that work
without
knowledge what kind of dream is this
this is impractical
um it's kind of practical um
i do think though let's say uh i
couldn't do anything
i'm also asking because there was a
point in time like when me and joe were
first doing jk
i pretty much like knew a b c d e what
it was going to be
like plan a through e if it didn't work
out what's b
uh i think so the first one it was gonna
be like cop where i was gonna like go
back in the military or i was gonna go
back to medical school or i was gonna be
like you know i had like
i knew the next five backups if
if it didn't work out now i think me and
joe are so involved in the industry
enough where like
we could you know work for a studio or
we could be in a marketing team or a
consulting team like there's enough like
doors open now
so um it would all be within kind of the
general realm
but i wanted to know like for you would
it still be in dance like would it go
into choreography or creative directing
we're like
i'll probably like leech onto this
company a lot more just be here i don't
need to you can't say
you know what i mean he'd be right here
i know that your gym is 88 compliant
there we are you could come there yeah
he won't do squats though
no you can't believe your thoughts only
uh but i think the point uh
just to for real be that i do enjoy
creation
the creative realm and and i i totally
agree with that uh
just being in the game long enough you
end up like kind of being in the pool of
the industry
yeah yeah so whether it's like actual
dancing actual choreographing or just
like
being within like the production lineup
that creates things
i think i would find joy from like
taking an idea
and then turning it into something that
people can be entertained by
i think i thoroughly like that and so it
doesn't have to be dance it's just
creatives in general
to be honest i was just saying this the
other day but i would actually love to
no longer dance for money
i would actually love to like have my
career that's what i was thinking my
career would be like you know cool and
just be financially free in different
ways so that if i wanted to dance i did
it because i wanted to not because i
thought it was part of my livelihood
you know yeah that's true because once
you start making money with your dream
the dream part kind of goes away yeah it
blends in
you kind of like organically like yo i'm
like living my dream but at the same
time like you
end up getting your passion put into
situations where like that's not exactly
your dream
you don't understand and it's not bad
it's just like
if i got steamrolled it's like no i
wouldn't be like i can't dance
yeah you know what i mean it would just
be for for money your heart but remember
you got steamrolled all the way up
to almost your dick area yeah so do you
would you like to change your answer
because of that you could dance
i would probably be a really really good
b-boy
oh you just swing swing the yeah like
b-boy junior you know that black dude
b-boy junior he has like one of his legs
is also kind of messed up
no right so uh there's there's a couple
dudes that also like kind of have
either no legs they're straight up there
paraplegics and stuff like that that go
in
is that their b-boy name no but because
they
they do everything with their arms in
general anyway they already have like
such upper body strength
when they do like flares with their like
fake legs and stuff you know what i mean
it's just like
way different strength dynamics
like we all know what that is because i
don't know he's he's a dancer see look
at that dude
it's like the gymnastics thing with that
on the palm oil he's got finger pliers
that's a pretty good finger do their
looks do their legs look floppy when
they do it
it's just a different animation i'll say
that to be like pc
is there a move where you see it all the
time and dancing you're like that's
[ __ ] hack i can't believe they're
still doing that [ __ ]
in dance yeah you mmm like sometimes
oh cause there's that in comedy like i'm
i'm that
uh i see that but i'm i'm the guy that
people are probably saying that about
really
yeah yeah there's like a move that's
like because right now it's all about
social dances and trends right online
right it's not about like oh
choreography it's like tick-tock dances
right so everybody does stuff right
yeah so i like there was this move that
came out maybe like 2017 or 18 it's
called the woe you guys ever see that
[ __ ] yes
everybody just like enlighten us oh wait
what does it do it again it was too fast
for me
it's exactly you know they like throw it
up and it's like whoa right and they
just like hit these whoa
okay and at first when he came out i was
like i didn't get it i was like i was
like okay cool everybody hits the beat
like at the same time okay i get it
right
fast forward a few months i started
doing joke woes right i don't know if
you guys ever saw my instagram when i
was just like randomly like throwing
hats
oh yeah and then just hitting it and
that [ __ ] got
[ __ ] viral as [ __ ] for me like like
crazy i probably got like
you know like tens of thousands of
followers on ig for like not even doing
real dancing and that's
social dance that's like social stuff
right whereas like i would put out my
actual choreography and i'll get like
like 30 000 views tossed like my real
[ __ ]
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by gabby insurance and did you know
that gabby stands for
get a better insurance how easy because
that's exactly what they do
it's a platform that compares all your
insurances
and they do apples to apples meaning
they don't they they align the same
deductible
the same coverage to make sure that you
know sometimes when you're doing it
yourself
it's like oh this is way cheaper and
then you look you zoom in you're like oh
this is only for half coverage this is
full coverage or this deductible is
higher
that one's lower so this one it takes
apples to apples comparisons
across all the insurance companies to
give you the best quote yeah and it's
like major ones too like progressive
nationwide and they have like 40
companies that they compared from
because when i first heard about this i
was like really
because i mean i know all the top
insurance companies and they're always
fighting for best rates
so how can something else give me a
better rate so
i wanted to go and check it out for
myself because i was like super
skeptical right and
um for my exact car i could get about 40
bucks a month off
wow yeah i mean i would do it but next
month i'm returning my car
but if i was keeping my car
this is something that is a super good
deal yeah yeah so if you're looking for
a way to save some money or just to
double check if you are indeed getting
the best rate across
all the insurance companies go to
gabby.com
off the record it's super easy to sign
up that's gabby.com
off the record i wish i knew this three
years ago when i got my lease
that's like us when we do comedy [ __ ]
and we're parodying something right and
it's like millions of views and then we
write like an original
that we really love also sick it's like
whatever
exactly so once once you like experience
that
the point is it's not to say like man
this [ __ ] sucks it's just like it didn't
suck
well i ended up just milking it i was
like look people love this you got to i
just milked it i was like [ __ ] it
i milked it it wasn't even like dancing
for it was always a joke
i always did it as a joke and people
like really loved it and then i got so
far that i i like
i wrote this like long thing that i was
like yo i'm tired of like the fans
forcing me to do these woes and stuff
psychologically messed up because all i
think about is bob and then i like i was
like i no longer do this is my last woe
ever
and it wasn't but it's still it was just
hilarious so you took yourself so
seriously i love it
yeah it was good it was good i think i i
should be a case study for social media
to be honest
are there are there lifting uh social
lifting oh yeah
he lifted like that there's uh there's
there's trends there's trends for sure
like what what the what's that so it'll
be like um
so so one of them was like you know
everyone always feels like they they
found
the thing right like everyone always
wants to find the solution
so there was this one like back exercise
i remember it's called the seal row
where like if you're laying on a bench
where you put a bench on weights because
then you have to lay on it and then you
do the dumbbell rolls like this
and uh usually if you're just on a
regular bench your hands would hit the
ground
so people set up like plates or blocks
whatever they do
elevated yeah so seal rows became a
thing and then so you would just see
almost every fitness person setting up
the stupidest contraption in every
single gym because
they don't make this machine but people
thought this is the best angle to hit
your back
and there's there's trends like that all
the [ __ ] time still
interesting yeah part yeah you got asked
to be a guest
on hot boxing with mike tyson how much
money do i have to pay you to wear that
shirt
zero zero dollars this one
you wear that that brain the frame
supreme
with all that he said about social media
it makes it so
you know you can talk all this [ __ ]
without ever getting punched in the face
oh yeah
you're going to wear that you're going
to wear a helmet
and maybe some pads underneath and a
mouth guard yeah a mouth guard and
[ __ ] elbow pads
but i think that's funny i bet you
that's what he's gonna say he's funny
all right badass he's probably seen it a
million times too supreme huh he's so
funny
what's up what's the uh workout trend
right now
the workout trend right now
so it's it's not usually it's always
like the same
the workouts don't change it's like um
but recently a word that i heard that i
never knew existed was filibuster
everyone talks about filibusters now i
don't know where it came from that's an
old world i thought that was in
law it's in it's in politics yeah but i
don't know it's just that's like there's
always like the word of the month or the
word you know i was thinking about
fuddruckers sorry
yeah but there's like filibuster so it's
like that like in fitness the workouts
don't really change but then also
they'll be like a key
like are your q's q's queues queues and
it's like that's the word
of like the month that people focus on
you know so what does it mean then
which one it's available filibuster is
it you is it used the same way
it's used to delay a bill usually
somebody stands up and they talk for
like
way longer than they even have to when
they start reading other books and [ __ ]
because
yeah they're able to delay alleged a
piece of legislation by filibustering
all right that's the idea behind it what
it is
i don't follow the trends so i i'm only
aware of it when i see it but i don't
really know or
do that i don't do the social like
lifting i just do whatever the [ __ ] i
want
but this is why i don't know artists i
don't grow very much
i probably should should do it's popular
i suck at that kind of stuff i thought
that the workout trend you're about to
talk about because i see these like
how far i follow barbell grade i always
crack up at the social videos where like
some people pretend to like trip over a
bar and then they pick up the thing with
their penis
yeah wait what i don't know it's all
viral games it's like it's like people
trip over the barbell and then they'll
stick their hands in their pants like
pick it up to like the software
that's just that's just the newer
generation i don't even understand their
comedy it's just crazy i don't
understand but i'll laugh
it makes me laugh i don't understand the
joke right no laughing for some reason
there's no there's no junk there they're
picking up the thing with a fake dick
that's hilarious
like don't be don't be ones like people
share pre-workout and they all take it
and like
nail fate and i don't understand what
the joke
i'm like i don't know what's going on
it's so strong i think a pretty good
joke so far
really picking up something with your
hand in your pants pretending it's your
dick when i was 13
i think i wouldn't even be able to
breathe if i saw that that's true yeah
i still do that i still like unzip my
pants sometimes stick my fingers in go
like this and wait for somebody to look
yeah especially at mcdonald's
[Laughter]
it's just nice to know that we're still
doing humor that they probably did
hundreds of years ago
oh yeah but they put it in their
trousers or whatever yeah they can fart
jokes yeah
they can fart jobs never gets old
they're taking pre-work
pre-workout like hundreds of years ago
pretending to pass out
that's good no question well other than
working out and [ __ ] dance if you
guys got steamrolled
how about steve where would you have you
got steamrolled up to your dick what
would you be doing still do i do
well you're gonna be the opposite
there's just your arms got steep you
can't tighten you can't tighten
you can't speed you can't run your
steamrolled the the steamroller
jumped over your head over your head but
smashed your shoulders
down to your pelvis you can't do what
you want to do shoulders down to pelvis
his legs are perfectly fine but his
whole upper body is just a wobbling
piece of paper
you can still do stand up
he actually can damn that's good
no no but his tongue was out if those
tongue got steamrolled too
i don't think i would want to live in
this scenario
you can't do any job i'm pc that's like
lieutenant dan
oh yeah oh no technically i would be
like lieutenant that's like stephen
hawkins
oh yeah yeah but yeah but like i guess
steamroller aside
if you can't do what you do now you
can't type on a computer
you can't you're such a generic
steamroller aside i didn't know
steamroller
okay steamroller there it's funny
because my backup was always i would
join the military
okay but then i couldn't do that that's
your backup because
you're aging out soon right alright 39 i
think
depending on the branch yeah but that
was always my
backup because i was just raised in that
where like you go in the military
so it's either comedy or military
basically what job would you take in the
military
i have no idea oh it's the kind of comic
yeah there you go i have no idea because
naval ships i know telling jokes the
entertainment
yeah not not uh intel i'll tell you that
not intel spy based off what i've heard
what have you heard what intel do you
have oh just she doesn't want to be a
honey pot
yeah no i don't i don't want to see all
the [ __ ] that we do
because those guys do and it can you can
[ __ ] you up even just seeing some of
this stuff good [ __ ]
yeah but like you're seeing [ __ ] up
close and personal you're seeing people
die up close and personal like in hd and
you can't do [ __ ] about it
i don't want to see that how about a
cook maybe
like the quartermaster you never leave
the camp you know what i mean like you
go to these places and you go yeah i
went to iraq
and everyone loves you too yeah and
you're like well thank you for your
service
like yeah i cook some really good ribs
or they hate you if you suck at cooking
no you never admit it you're like i went
to iraq
and then you you act like a badass but
then somebody looks you up later and
they're like wait he was just a [ __ ]
cook
do cooks get like mellow honors i guess
if they get bombed
they're still in there mean because in
war some [ __ ] [ __ ] can happen to anybody
you know that's true for kitchen
i'd give them a medal of honor if
they're lobster or like steak was really
good
what was that movie with uh cuba cuba
goodie journey junior
men of honor men of honor you mean
robert downey jr where he's like [ __ ]
like holding his breath in the scuba
gear no no the other one does no armor
pearl harbor right yeah he was a cook he
was a cook
and then he went to go man the machine
gun so he was a cook
but yeah so it's like anything could
happen you know also
under siege with stephen cigal is based
on the true story and it's about a
a cook who ends up fighting tommy lee
jones
yeah tommy jones was trying to take over
the ship stevenson was a cook in the
movie he was a creepy
classic lion well why don't you just
think about of course cooks get medal of
honor
two of them right there i don't know
what's that freak stephen cigar black
hawk dad was about a ton of cooks
they're all jumping out of the
helicopter
were they all cooked yeah not anyone
yeah they're all they're all of them
single little every war movie yeah
they're navy cooks yeah yeah
oh it cooks that hog down was a fun
movie i really enjoyed it when i was
young
really i don't like warm movies you know
like war movies
i've never heard anyone say i don't like
women really what do you like about me
it's probably the first time i heard
that they're
they're stressful in a way that you're
supposed to be
is an entire genre in the dustbin yeah
yeah
they're stressful in a way that's not
very fun dude that's how i feel about
emotional movies that make you cry i'm
like thank you
i know you do no you know what you know
what movie that i really like that's
really stressful that no one else seems
to like is [ __ ] uncut gems and
[ __ ]
i love uncut gems yeah i love those i
love that i thought it was great until
the end
i still like that ending's the [ __ ]
best thing i thought danny's the worst
part ever do you think
do you think he had a uh do you think he
thought of himself as a winner
or a loser i mean i'm not gonna spoil it
just a winner of course winner
yeah of course i like uncatching because
it's stressful from the beginning of the
movie to the end
yeah we'll never watch it and you're
like how the [ __ ] can anyone live like
this but then i know a ton of people
that do
it was so good but then the end just
completely sucked ass for me so would
that genre be though
what's that what would the genre
thriller right yeah what are those
movies in general where they're just
uncomfortable the whole time regardless
and there's the ending doesn't make you
feel better
or i guess [ __ ] them the genre who are
those people
that makes those kind of movies i love
watching those like they just like love
being uncomfortable twisted people
i like the being uncomfortable part but
i just didn't find it satisfying it's
like a million dollar baby
you guys see a million dollar baby i
haven't seen that one yeah i have okay
oh yeah that one's
we're like seven brad pitt that's just a
great movie though
great movie but it's not to say that i
like enjoy watching it because it makes
you feel like [ __ ]
yeah but it's got a great beginning
middle and end to it and it almost
because we watch that yeah i can
acknowledge this amazing movie i'm just
saying it makes
you kind of feel like [ __ ] yeah
mine was pursuit of happiness that's the
one i will never watch i was like what
the [ __ ] dude it's like these guys can't
catch a break for the whole movie and
then they barely get a break and i'm
like that's it
that's the category of movies that i'm
talking about though
and shittier i will never see yeah yeah
that's why we stick to like princess
diaries and stuff right good stuff
cat in the hat it's my favorite movie of
all time with mike myers great payoff
it's great comedy i didn't like the
ending
[Laughter]
the house got fixed up took me out of it
you